after 12 years and 279 episodes the big
bang theory wrapped up its run in 2019
and the final shows were crammed full of
references to past storylines and
characters
here's a look at everything that went
down and why it all matters to the
overall big bang theory universe
long-running sitcom finales almost
always involve a big dramatic event
characters move away or a romantic will
they or won't they thread ends happily
or some other big goal is achieved
for a show like the big bang theory
about adults who have almost all married
and become successful in their
professions that kind of big change
wouldn't have rung true
instead the writers found an ending that
made sense for its world-class scientist
characters while also resolving a plot
line that stretched throughout the
show's 12th and final season
physicist sheldon cooper and his wife
neuroscientist amy farrell fowler win
the nobel prize for physics for their
work on super asymmetry
it's the ultimate goal of every
scientist and one sheldon specifically
and frequently mentioned throughout the
series
so you really think that i'm the kind of
man who would sell out his partner for
the chance of winning a nobel
prize are you
boy i hope not receiving this honor also
gives the show an excuse for a big
destination finale
so you guessed it the whole gang decides
to accompany sheldon and amy to the
nobel awards ceremony in sweden
over the course of nearly 300 episodes
the big bang theory developed quite a
few running gags recurring bits and even
unsolved mysteries
the finale gave fans what they wanted
delivering on those lengthy setups and
wrapping things up nicely along the way
viewers finally learn why leonard
dresses the way he does
forever sporting at least two layers on
his upper body despite living in sunny
california
leonard reveals that he's always rocking
a hooded sweatshirt because he's
constantly chilly
this of course is sheldon's fault he
insists that the thermostat be kept at
an uncomfortably low temperature
the show's longest running gag is also
resolved after years of walking up and
down the stairs a mechanical miracle
occurs
with a simple ding penny emerges from
the elevator that's been out of order
since the first episode aired in 2007
you believe it they finally fixed the
elevator
plus a couple of the show's most
predominant recurring characters get
cameos in the final episodes
doing exactly the type of things that
made them so beloved
john ross bowie reprises his role as
sheldon's workplace nemesis barry
he prank calls a very nervous sheldon as
he waits to hear from the nobel
committee
also the perpetually unlucky steward
shows up for a quick scene
howard and bernadette video chat with
him as they realized he was the wrong
person to babysit their children
okay so everyone's happy and healthy
well that depends
what's that mean how many teeth did
halle have on your left
even a double episode with nearly 45
minutes of running time however wasn't
enough to wrap up every storyline from
the show's extensive past
when the series began in 2007 all four
male main characters were single and
socially awkward
by the end three of them sheldon leonard
and howard found love and are happily
married
that just leaves raj the most loved lord
of them all as the sole bachelor
the series ends with raj just as single
as when it started although he almost
got married in the final season
luckily there may be a glimmer of hope
for his love life on the flight over to
sweden raj ends up in a seat next to
sarah michelle gellar who is tv's buffy
the vampire slayer
somehow he manages to convince her to
attend the nobel ceremony with him which
was a huge surprise to everyone
is that buffy the vampire slayer
and as for the big bang theory's most
enduring question well it didn't get
answered and it probably never will
before she became mrs penny hofstadter
penny's last name was never mentioned
even when relatives visited writers were
careful to let the mystery remain
unsolved
a huge amount of the show stories jokes
and character quirks revolved around
sheldon being picky self-centered
arrogant controlling and unabashed about
all of it i'm sorry did i upset you yes
ask me how i feel about that
most viewers have probably wondered why
amy and the others can tolerate such an
intolerable man
throughout the finale almost every
character has finally had enough of
sheldon's behavior and they let him know
it
leonard confronts him when after being
told that penny is pregnant
sheldon's merely glad that she's got
morning sickness and not a virus that he
might catch
when sheldon tells amy that he doesn't
intend to be so mean she drops the bomb
that this obliviousness is the only
reason why his entire group of friends
hasn't walked out on him
sheldon's behavior is so terrible that
howard bernadette leonard and penny all
make plans to head home early and skip
the ceremony but this is an upbeat
network sitcom so that's not gonna
happen
the whole gang is in the audience when
amy and sheldon accept science's highest
honor
both characters deliver touching
speeches one speaks to the show's legacy
and the other provides a happy
tear-jerking moment
the big bang theory casually demystified
science for millions and probably
inspired more than a few kids to be
scientists
in real life actress mayam bialik has a
phd in neuroscience from ucla
reflecting this passion her character
amy gives a powerful speech encouraging
young girls to dream of a career in
science to go for it no matter what
it is the greatest job in the world
and if anybody tells you you can't don't
listen then it's sheldon's turn
stun that his friends have stuck around
to cheer him on after his terrible
behavior he ignores the novel-length
self-aggrandizing speech he prepared
instead he speaks from the heart and
thanks his friends and wife for their
years of support
sheldon also apologizes for not always
being a great friend and lets them know
how he truly feels
but i want you to know in my way
i love you all this beloved series could
very well have ended in that auditorium
in sweden but that was just the show's
climax
it needed an epilogue at its heart the
big bang theory is a show about
friendship and how powerful it is when
misfits grow up and create their own
families of kindred spirits
so much of the series consisted of the
seven featured characters hanging out in
the main apartment set
gathering each evening to eat takeout
and that was the perfect final image for
the big bang theory
a group of close friends casually
hanging out as the camera eases away and
the series fades into tv history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one